[Musique]
avec vous là une frappe bonjour Hélène
bonjour Pauline à la Une Hélène une
image qui fait le tour du monde depuis
hier et quelle image la photo des
joueurs de l'équipe de foot iranienne
qui ont refusé de chanter l'hymne
national avant leur premier match de
Coupe du monde face à l'Angleterre avec
le silence des joueurs Iraniens qui ont
ainsi voulu dénoncer la répression en
cours dans leur pays trouve un écho
retentissant dans la presse à travers le
monde je vous propose de commencer par
le quotidien libanais L'Orient-Le Jour
qui évoque le défi des footballeurs
iraniens au régime de Téhéran d'après le
journal leur silence et le fruit d'une
décision collective et leur vaut une
popularité nouvelle auprès des
manifestants et des détracteurs du
régime il a provoqué en tout cas une
grande émotion chez les supporters
iraniens présents dans les tribunes hier
du stade de Khalifa de Doha le visage de
l'un de ses supporters bouleversés fait
la une du quotidien français Libération
l'arme du silence le quotidien parle
d'un moment de mondovision tellement
incroyable que l'on pouvait se demander
si le son n'avait pas été coupé pour
l'Iran la rencontre d'hier était bien
plus qu'un match d'après le quotidien
britannique de Guardian et qui a retenu
lui la photo de supporters
le drapeau national et reprenant le
slogan des manifestants anti-riges
femmes vit liberté le quotidien
britannique salut ce matin le geste
puissant et courageux je cite des
joueurs d'Iraniens un geste présenté
comme une petite merveille dans une
coupe du monde du malheur cette équipe
de foot n'est pas une extension des
dirigeants iraniens mais tout le
contraire ce groupe agit comme un
amplificateur pour la liberté et la
modernité ce n'est pas hasard une
coïncidence il les iraniennes ont été
bannis des terrains de foot depuis
1979 parce que c'est cela que craint le
régime la spontanéité et le sens du
collectif le régime mais avec lui la
presse officiels qui fourmille de ne
rien voir de ne rien entendre il est
temps d'aller de l'avant titre ce matin
de Iron daily qui n'évoque nulle part le
silence des joueurs mais uniquement
leurs résultats sportif la défaite face
aux Anglais 6 6 Buzet 2 le quotidien
iranien officiel qui évoque aussi à la
Une les frappes du régime contre les
groupes d'opposition Kurdes iraniens
basée au Kurdistan d'Irak des groupes
qualifiés de terroristes par Téhéran
beaucoup de réactions également ce matin
Hélène à la décision de la FIFA la
Fédération internationale le foot de
sanctionner les joueurs aborderont un
brassard arc-en-ciel à l'occasion de
cette Coupe du monde en soutien au droit
des homosexuels Pride and Prejudice
Orgueil et Préjugés titre ce matin le
Daily Mirror en reprenant le roman
éponyme de diagnostin l'orgueil la
fierté évidemment après la victoire des
Anglais mais le regret de voir la FIFA
se plier au préjugés du Qatar ou
l'homosexualité est passible de sept ans
de prison le tabloïde critique la
décision honteuse du patron de la FIFA
Janine Fantino d'empêcher les joueurs
européens d'exprimer leur soutien le
brassard de la discorde le journal belge
Le Soir regrette que les 7 équipes les 7
équipes européennes dont la Belgique est
renoncée à ce geste symbolique et
dénonce une coupe du monde de tous les
cynisme indignation aussi des
dessinateurs de presse je commence par
mot tellement là pour The Times qui
montrent on le voit les trois le
troisième lieu anglais se débarrassant
de son brassard One Love allusion à
l'engagement du capitaine des tweets
Lion's Harry Kane de porter ce brassard
un engagement donc sur lequel il est
finalement revenu beaucoup d'illusions
aussi à l'anaphore de Gianni Infantino à
la veille du Mondial aujourd'hui je me
sens gai aujourd'hui je me sens
handicapée aujourd'hui je me sens
travailleurs immigrés engagement donc
auquel il a renoncé sous la pression des
sponsors d'après le dessinateur Mister
tee le patron de la FIFA un qu'on
retrouve arrachant un morceau de
l'arc-en-ciel de l'arc-en-ciel LGBT un
dessin signé néo-sunero et publié par le
site cartoon movement pas de polémique
en tout cas pas pour le moment chez les
Bleus qui affront ce soir l'Australie
privée de Benzema vous l'avez dit quand
tu es époque bah les champions du du
monde en titre j'en parle en latin se
retrouve soumis à une pression maximale
on compte sur vous le Parisien
Aujourd'hui en France se rappelle que
depuis 1962 le Brésil est le seul
champion du monde avoir réussi à
conserver son titre on dit ça on ne dit
rien à l'unisson de feu le groupe
Téléphone le quotidien sportif L'Équipe
rêve d'un autre monde d'une nouvelle
coupe du monde un autre monde possible
début de réponse ce soir face à
l'Australie sans transition pour
terminer Hélène un mot de cette décision
inédite en France où le tribunal
judiciaire de Paris à interdit vendredi
au site d'informations Mediapart de
publier de nouvelles révélations sur les
pratiques politiques du maire de
Saint-Étienne mise en cause dans une
affaire de chantage présumée à la
sextape la décision judiciaire est
présentée par média partent comme un
acte de censure préalable sans débat
contradictoires comme je cite une
attaque sans précédent contre la liberté
de la presse l'association Reporters
sans frontières quant à elle alerte sur
un contournement dangereux et flagrant
de la loi de juillet 1880 qui protège la
liberté de la presse et le Syndicat
national des journalistes appellent de
son côté toutes les organisations de
défense des libertés publiques à
soutenir le site d'investigation
Mediapart et nous serons pour en parler
à 9h15 avec Fabrice Arfi de Mediapart
merci beaucoup Hélène on